140 at msu's working hall.
>> So, he entered the classroom
from to the back door.
Where a lot of the students
that don't sit in the front,
they sit by that backdoor.
And at that moment, we all kind
of froze.
I think somebody said something
about, you know, a shooter and
one of my students, and
everybody panicked.
Some froze.
I think a lot of them stood up.
Some of them froze in place,
some of them, I don't know if I
screamed just, you know, find
cover under the desks.
A lot of them went under.
Curled up in a ball under their
chairs and others ran, and the
guy stepped in about a foot
inside the classroom.
Not completely just, like, a
foot.
And or even less than a foot.
Enough that I could see this
figure, and it was so horrible
because, you know, when you see
someone who's totally masked,
you don't see their face, you
don't see their hands, you
don't see, it was like seeing a
robot.
It was like seeing something in
human standing there, and all I
could see was this silvery kind
of steel shine weapon.
I don't think it was a pistol,
I think it was something larger
than that.
And then I could hear the shots,
and they were just as loud as
the ones in the hallway.
It was just a nightmare.
I think everybody under
adrenaline did whatever they
could.
I don't know how long he stood
there.
Probably, I mean, he shot at
least 15 shots.
One after the other, one after
the other, one after the other.
Bang, bang, bang.
He stepped out and at that
moment, because I don't recall
what I did between him starting
to shoot and what I'm going to
tell you just now.
I just, my intuition told me
he's walking down the hall and
he's going to enter through the
door.
I'm closest to it, so I threw
myself at that door and I
squatted, and I held the door
like this, so that my weight
would keep it from and I was
putting my foot on the wall,
and holding like this, so that
he couldn't open it.
All the time, aware that he
could just shoot the door
handle and open it.
But the only thing I thought I
could do was that.
At least attempt to stop it.
And that lasted for about ten
minutes, felt like an eternity.
Or 12 minutes.
In the meantime, I told my
students and that, I remember.
I told the students, just
escape through the windows.
Kick the windows open, escape
through the windows.
And the first line of windows
closer to the row of seats
could not be kicked.
I mean, cannot be broken.
They're made out a very hard
glass.
Probably for, you know,
insulation.
So, they attempted and they
couldn't open those, but then
the second set of windows
higher up, they were open and
there was an opening big enough,
so they started escaping that
way.
In the meantime, the rest,
there were quite a few on the
floor wounded, and I had some
kids that were very heroic.
That were helping those that
were wounded and some of them,
I don't know much about how to,
you know, what paramedics do or
what you do in a situation like
that, but my students kind of
knew what to do, so they were
trying to cover their wounds
with their hands, so they
wouldn't bleed to death.
I think I will be haunted by
it.
I definitely don't want to go
to --
because I couldn't go into that
classroom after what I saw.
I think the administration is
going to move my class to a
different building.
At the same time, but a
I don't know if I will be
nervous every time I teach.
I don't know if I will, I don't
know what the university is
going to do.
They are going to put locks in
rooms, so that you can lock the
room from the inside.
I think that's one of the
things that might happen.
I don't know that means we are